you guys welcome to the State Department
just a couple things at the top and then
I'll turn to your questions first of all
and today I'm pleased to announce we're
releasing the first ever joint USAID
State Department's strategy on
preventing and countering violent
extremism continuing to build on the
efforts launched at the February 2015
White House summit this strategy
provides a road map with five strategic
objectives to meet the challenge of
radicalization to violence and as well
as terrorist recruitment state and USAID
will work together closely with other US
government and key international
partners to advance all five of these
strategic objectives using the full
range of diplomatic development and
foreign assistance tools both the
strategy itself and the factsheet will
be available after today's briefing in
addition the Bureau of counterterrorism
has has formally transitioned to the
Bureau of counterterrorism and
countering violent extremism secretary
Kerry is empowering the newly renamed
Bureau to serve as the lead for
coordinating the State Department's CVE
engagement and assistance the bureau's
expanded CVE office will continue to
work closely with US government partners
CVE partners including USAID the
interagency global engagement center and
others
USAID is also increasing its focus on
CVE by establishing a secretariat to
coordinate its programming and to ensure
collaboration with other governmental
departments and development institutions
and just final note here the State
Department's acting counterterrorism
coordinator Justin Saburo I will be
speaking about this a new approach in a
speech today at the George Washington
program on countering violent extremism
and also turning to Liberia today in New
York the UN Security Council adopted a
resolution that ends the UN arms embargo
on Liberia this step reflects the
significant and steady advances by the
people and the government of Liberia
towards restoring peace and security for
all Liberians
more than 12 years after the end of
Liberia's brutal civil war and the
council's imposition of sanctions the
people of Liberia have made important
progress in building democratic
institutions and healing the wounds of
the past today's resolution is a notable
example of how multilateral tools such
as sanctions are an effective means of
encouraging the kind of progress we've
seen over the past decade in Liberia
first question I went orders yesterday
I'll go AP today and then go ahead
alright can I start with the IG report
on the email practices okay do you agree
with what seems to be the essential
conclusion regarding specifically past
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton's
email practices that she essentially
played by her own rules well Brad so
I'll try to address your questions but
I'm at a bit of a disadvantage and the
reason why is that you know as often
happens in Washington DC but this report
is not due for public release until
tomorrow and so I know that some of the
some in the media did receive leaked
copies of the report and so I'm somewhat
limited and to the extent I can go into
because I don't want to talk about the
report's conclusions in great detail
until that reports been released
publicly but what we have been saying in
general about the OIG report and and and
the process is that that was something
that secretary Kerry asked of the OIG to
do you know undertake this review they
have made recommendations we've already
complied with many of those
recommendations in the report that
you'll see and that it does the report
highlight the challenges that the State
Department but all as well as other
federal agencies are facing and trying
to ensure proper record-keeping and
accountability for email traffic
wait yes sir question now that you've
gone through all of that
sure and since you briefed you gave a
background briefing which I guess was
anonymous spin I don't see why you can't
address something at an open press
briefing well again I'll you can try
your question again but you know I'm
limit you said you would address the
questions here's the problem Brad you
know and we we are precedent here we
don't talk about leaked documents we
don't often address them and we do this
across the board you did this morning in
a conference call well we had to address
through a background briefing and I take
objection to your allegation that it's
some kind of spin effort we were simply
trying to get out there on background to
talk about some of the allegations or
the some of the findings rather in this
report since it was out in public
yeah sure please and I understand you
have some limitations but but I think
that there are institutional questions
that ought to be addressed
okay one of the findings in the in the
report was that the Secretary Clinton or
the OIG found no evidence that Secretary
Clinton ever sought approval for her use
of a private server and it also quotes
the chief information officer who I
believe is part of IRM right and the
assistant secretary for Diplomatic
Security as saying that they believe
that she had an obligation to ask them
and that if they had been asked they
would have declined it declined to
improve it
the report also explicitly states that
the Undersecretary of management
discussed the issue with some of the
secretaries top staff the Undersecretary
of management is directly responsible
for the bureaus for IRM correct yes
I mean people can't see or nod exactly
is the undersecretary manager
responsible for IRM and for DES do that
both report to him yes
yep why didn't the undersecretary
management who is responsible for the
two bureaus that complained that they
should have been asked but weren't to
approve this
why didn't he raise it so let me try to
broadly answer your the point you've
raised or the issues you've raised first
of all about whether secretary clinton
was required to seek approval you know
and we talked about this in the past so
i feel like i can speak about it on the
record now is that you know well not
necessarily encourage there was no
prohibition on using personal email the
only requirement is that regulations do
state does that these records need to be
preserved and you know i would say
looking back with 20/20 hindsight you
know we do now have records management
and cybersecurity policies that would
make it hard to approve this kind of
outside system to replace your official
email you know and Secretary Clinton has
said publicly no she didn't or she would
not make the same choice again she's
also said she did not seek a specific
approval for this system and I am aware
that senior state Department officials
noted in the report said they wouldn't
have approved her exclusive reliance on
a personal email to conduct official
business you know I'm not going to
challenge that assertion those
assertions as I said she herself had
said she would not have done it the same
way or made the same choice again but I
don't want to reel it again
all of that and and frankly I'm not sure
that the report gets into the it's a
assigning blame on that but mark one
funny when I said one thing here I mean
the report says you state that there was
no absolute prohibition on the use of
personal email which is true however
beginning in late 2005 and continuing
through 2011 the Department written
revised the fort Affairs manual and you
should various memoranda specifically
discussing the obligation to use
Department systems in most circumstances
so there was an obligation to use
Department systems in most circumstances
correct if you're quoting me chapter and
verse I'm not going to dispute that but
it wasn't prohibited in it in occasional
circumstances but it was prohibited in
to do it in every circumstance because
the obligation here is that in most
circumstances you have to use the
department systems so when you say it's
not absolutely prohibited you're right
but you're not right if you use that
statement to suggest that it was
acceptable to use it in most
circumstances because Secretary Clinton
used it in every circumstance correct
but again in answer to your second
question while people were aware of her
use of personal email no one had a full
and complete understanding of to the
extent some people did have a full and
complete understanding he's dead like
she did right well again and that's a
question for her and her team to answer
but there is a reason I'm raising this
and there's not an institutional
question because you guys you know you
have an interest it would seem to me in
securing the communications yes we do of
the top tip on that right and therefore
it's not just for her to ask but surely
isn't it for the people around her
including the Undersecretary of manage
who did discuss this issue with her top
aides to raise these issues and so I
want to go apologize I'm not sure what
you're referring specifically about he
did discuss these issues on page 38 it
says in August 2011 the executive
secretary the undersecretary for
management and secretary of Clinton's
chief of staff and deputy chief of staff
in response to the Secretary's request
discussed via email providing her with a
blood department blackberry to replace
her personal blackberry which was
malfunctioning possibly because quote
and this email has been released her
quote her personal email server is down
so the Undersecretary of management the
chief of staff an unidentified deputy
chief of staff all discuss this issue
via email the undersecretary management
is responsible for the two bureaus IR m
and D s who's safe that they believe the
secretary had an obligation to ask her
permission ask for approval T is this
and who say that if they had been asked
they would have said no and I don't
understand why their boss so wouldn't
have addressed this issue because he's
responsible for both of them and he
discussed it with the top officials in
the department including the chief of
staff it is our understanding our shot
that that that the full extent of her
use of private email was not clear to
senior staff now what you're referring
to is the two men who her deputies her
chief of staff didn't know this her
again people were where she was using it
I can't speak to to that specifically
you're talking about undersecretary for
management didn't know what I can say is
and so just just to finish my response I
think we referring to as knowing in to
use an expressive 20/20 hindsight that
these two senior state Department
officials then said they would not have
approved of this again I don't I think
Secretary Clinton has said as much that
she looking back would not have done the
same
the same course of action I also want to
say sorry Hartman make an effort because
some people didn't know it she knew it
her chief of staff knew it and her
undersecretary for management to some
degree that was aware that she had a
personal email but I did know that there
was a discussion of replacing it and you
that that was ultimately rejected so I
don't get why the Department
understanding it has such an obligation
to secure communications would not at a
senior level responsible both for
information technology and diplomatic
security wouldn't have raised this and
flagged it as an issue so you would be
in keeping with your own rules so again
look out waiting too much into the
details of this which I'm uncomfortable
doing given that it's not gone public
yet but a couple of things one is we
have said in the past and continue to
say that you know our you know our
record-keeping we could have done a
better job at preserving emails and
records of secretaries of state and
their senior staff going back frankly
several administrations so back to
before
Secretary Clinton we recognize that I
will also make the point that you know
the fact that she turned over some you
know 52,000 pages of her emails and I
think o IG recognized that in some ways
mitigated those past preservation
problems you're talking about and I get
your your question which is you know was
there knowledge if there was knowledge
why weren't steps taken I'm not gonna
relitigate that I just am not you know
the OIG report has its conclusions has
its recommendations we've worked to
address those recommendations we
acknowledge that we need to do a better
job with our record-keeping we believe
we're doing such we've taken
steps to meet all of the recommendations
of the OIG reporters has made and in
fact the OIG has said that we are in
compliance or has rather that they
consider all photos that that all eight
recommendations have been resolved
issues on this so in the background
briefing yeah one official said
repeatedly that the report says that we
didn't do a great job
the phrase great job and didn't do a
great job appear nowhere in the port the
reports conclusion states the department
generally and the office of the
secretary in particular had been slow to
recognize and to manage effectively the
legal requirements and cybersecurity
risks associated with elect on
electronic data communications and in
its opening one page summary it says
management weaknesses that the
Department have contributed to the loss
or removal of email records particularly
records created by the office of the
secretary these weaknesses include a
limited ability to retrieve email
records in accessibility of electronic
files failure to comply with the
requirements for departing employees and
a general lack of oversight do you
believe that the official was truthful
in stating we didn't do a great job
because great job he said that the
report says that over and over again the
phrase is not there and what it says is
that there were systemic weaknesses and
management weaknesses and a general lack
of oversight and I asked this because
the briefing was on background and I
believe people should be accountable for
what they say and the accuracy of it and
I don't see why an official would say we
didn't do a great job that the report
says that when that's not actually what
the report says the report says there
were systemic failures and management
weaknesses and a general lack of
oversight that's not we didn't do a
great job that's you had you know why is
do you believe that official was correct
into making that statement you know
look I'm not going to parse the
expression he used to acknowledge the
fact that we like many federal agencies
we're not doing enough to meet the
requirements of records management and
preservation
I think we've acknowledged that I've
acknowledged it just now on the record
and yet moving forward we believe we
have set in place at the direction or
under the direction of secretary Kerry
efforts to fully comply and meet and
improve our records management and
preservation system here at the State
Department and you know I mean again I
don't mean the you know to broaden the
lens here but you know agencies across
the federal government have been working
to adapt to you know unbelievably enough
you know the because emails have been
around for a while but you know the fact
that we live in an email dominated
business environment these days and yet
we still were relying up to a few years
ago on this print and file system which
is inadequate we recognize that and we
have set in motion so I'm that so it's
your question or your allegation
notwithstanding we acknowledge truth we
acknowledge the question whether the guy
was no but I don't think the cloak of
anonymity should be sufficient for not
talk telling the truth about what a
report says I don't think it was I don't
think so sorry Brad I'll get you in a
second so with all due respect Arshad
the quote/unquote cloak of anonymity it
was a background briefing that we set up
which is a common practice all of you
know in this room we do background
briefings all the time in order to add a
little bit more depth in context that we
might add regularly on the record for a
lot of obvious reasons so we can give
you guys more information or share that
some of the inner workings I'm going to
finish on this there's not any effort to
spin this there's not in the effort to
hide or abuse Kate about what the
information is
but I will also acknowledge that one of
the reasons we did this on background
acknowledging the fact that
you know other people who were privy to
this report before it was publicly
released chose to leak it to members of
the media so you see the dynamic here
and we're none of us are our Queen on
this so to speak in the sense that you
know you guys all got the report leaked
to you or many of you did but not all of
you did and an attempt to address that
we held this background telephone press
conference to try to address some of
your questions we had no choice but it
is always our preference that this stuff
is released publicly and then we can
discuss it pausing the implication on
the call was that the department didn't
educate people enough wouldn't Clinton
as the head of the entire department
isn't that her responsibility not the
department's responsibility to her
that's the first one I mean so first of
all you're right and that we have said
that we did not do a good enough job in
in processing and out processing to put
it in a bureaucratic way our senior
officials but even as an institution so
that people were aware of you know what
the regulations were right I only say
that a lot of these regulations have
only kind of been thought about and
formulated since she left office in 2013
specifically was menara came out with
kind of new and improved recommendations
and looked at this so report says the
guidance the guidance was considerably
more detailed and sophisticated by
Clinton's tenured and her security
practices should be evaluated
accordingly but be that as it may you
you may be reference again that not
everyone knew that that the Senate
passed secretary only used private email
wasn't that her responsibility to let
them know in fact there is no other way
they would have known crap well not
that's honestly true but as an
institution again we acknowledge that we
could have done more to but that's her
responsibility isn't it it even says
here Secretary Clinton had an obligation
to discuss using their personal email
account to conduct official business
with their offices
not they had an obligation to learn
independently about you better I'm sorry
I think we're talking about just a power
that it was her responsibility to inform
the department about regulations or no
talking about her using a private email
and private server again I'll just go
back to what I said before which is that
you know it wasn't encouraged but it was
not prohibited
there were hack attempts on her server
how did that not bring the reassessment
that maybe this isn't and then I
apparently just got plugged back in how
did that not bring a reassessment that
maybe this wasn't the best strategy well
I don't know again and I you know oog
specifically addresses the security of
her system he says that she never told
anybody about her hack hack attempts or
that but none of them were successful
how do you know that none of them very
successful I would just have to refer
you to the how do you know that because
the report does not say that none of
them were successful I apologize
actually I misspoke yeah but I will say
but I but I just would refer you to
secretary Clinton's team to for
questions about the security of her
system yeah I was gonna count no there
you just a fair amount of discussion
about the fact that when there was a
comparison made with the the three
secretaries who used it almost
exclusively and in that section that
Brad just quoted they said specifically
that the rules were clearly in line
we're clearly in place by the time the
secretary came in they were much more
sophisticated so when you compare what
secretary Powell did and what Secretary
Clinton did even though this morning
many people said there it was said
repeatedly that this was a problem going
back several administer
Asians do you not see a difference
between what secretary Powell did and
what Secretary Clinton did again I'm not
gonna you know litigate from this podium
or compare and contrast I think that
what we've said is that you know the
policies the regulations regarding the
use of private email have only really
been clarified in the past several years
up until that point again understanding
that it was not encouraged to use
personal email but it was not prohibited
and I think that this is an evolving
process in the sense that not
exclusively to the State Department I
might add in a sense that you know many
agencies are struggling with how to
preserve and manage records keeping for
email use official emails versus
personal emails again I mean there are
circumstances and we've talked about
this before where senior officials
sometimes you have to use personal email
he only ever given in the report was
secretary Powell so but it would seem
that they they seem to go out of their
way to try to distinguish between two
you do not see a difference they I'm
sorry David in the report the report
seemed to distinguish between between
the circumstances in the sense in that
section Brad just quoted well I think
again I would only say that it's been an
evolving understanding of the some of
the challenges and records keeping
involving personal email but also in the
sense that you know you know we've also
been and I mentioned this to Brad you
know how we we need to do a better job
and we believe we are doing a better job
at onboarding out processing senior
officials so that they are
damn this constraints and and the rules
and the regulations surrounding use of
personal email versus official you
believe secretary Powell after doing
properly I'm not gonna make that
judgment sorry sorry so I had eyes one
about the legal as well um and okay
we'll get to you I promise we just how
we normally do is we run through so um
so this may already be known and I might
have missed this but are we or am I
wrong to have assumed that all of the
emails in the state all of secretary
Clinton's emails in the State
Department's possession would have been
released to the public via the FOIA page
or do you in fact have a number of
emails that didn't meet those standards
for without weren't involved in the FOIA
request and therefore you're holding a
number of her you know so we haven't
seen so what we have released through
our monthly for you process that all of
you love so much was approximately
55,000 pages of emails that Secretary
Clinton provided to the department I
think at the time she said she does not
have a tour that she does not have
access to any work-related emails beyond
those that she turned over to the
department so she did not keep rather
thank you she's not keep work-related
emails beyond though she turned over to
the department so in answer to your
question we've what we've done to the
FOIA process is turn over all the emails
that she turned over the State
Department and we have found in
additional things I'm not saying that
you know when you have replies and other
that there are additional emails out
there and in this case is I think a case
of such an example do you estimate that
you have a deaths that have not been
made up I don't think we have an
estimate and I don't think it's a large
number I just think that there are stray
examples like this okay because some of
them seem to be
quite relevant as in this November 2010
email in which she's so one of her chief
deputy Chiefs has suggests she set up a
state relevant to what I mean the the
for us what was the FOIA request was
what there was an offer by her to
release all those emails well whatever
the case may be that some of the emails
that you still have in your possession
seems relevant to her to her decision to
keep a private email rather than use the
state gov one which is essentially the
entire question so I'm just wondering if
it if you are interested in releasing
any of those emails relevant to this
whole discussion about that I can't
speak to that
you know we certainly if there's
additional FOIA requests we would if she
had written all of these emails on a
state of give account would it have been
for the State Department eyes to decide
which ones were personal and which ones
were official oh well it's still have
been her team that decided which ones
that she would offer through the FOIA
process is the ones you've released or
ones that she decided were relevant if
she had sent them originally through an
official account would she have had the
right to choose which ones were official
it's good question
i I don't know when can you take I can
look into it certainly because when I
and the reason I ask is I don't know if
for example I was for you whether I
would have kind of first right to say
here's all my official emails or not and
then they would then be vetted properly
I just don't know the answer what is
secretary kerry's system for receiving
and sending emails well secretary Kerry
relies primarily on his state gov
account for work and the emails on a
state gov account are automatically
archived and this is an improvement this
is part of the advancements that we've
made so any email that he sends is
automatically copied and remotely saved
electronically and
again this speaks to the fact that we're
now complying this automatic archiving
approach does comply with the federal
Records Act as well as email records
management requirements so and he sends
mercies that through computer here in
the building of the access to a mobile
device with state.gov
I believe has the State Department
released all the emails that Secretary
Clinton turned over yes then why on the
background call was there a discussion
of an email that an official admitted
was not released to the public because
it wasn't part of that tranche of emails
that she turned over and I just if I
explain that poorly I apologize there
are other emails out there and she has
said that that she only turned over what
she still had in her possession so that
does not exclude the fact that there are
other responses replies you know how
email works where where there is a the
body of her an email from her that was
not reflected in the terms and the
amount of email emails there can be and
I just don't have an accurate number I
will double-check I don't know that
we've even looked her as he sings turn
up but it's not like what are some huge
cash you know this did this the State
Department mislead the American public
when it came to secretary Clinton's
emails in the past year no I don't
believe so at all in fact we've always
said that we were simply going through
and we've been very clear about this
almost tediously so when we talk to you
guys about it is that systematically
every month we went through this 55,000
pages of emails that she gave to us
through the FOIA process we edited
upgraded them as necessary but before we
released them publicly but we only dealt
with what we received from Secretary
Clinton the IG is saying that Secretary
Clinton was not in compliance with State
Department email policy yet for the past
year all we've been hearing about from
that podium is that the Secretary was in
compliance we haven't said that either
what we said is that and I believe and
I'm I'm Brad can can yell at me because
I'm waiting into the into the report's
findings but they did say that
the fact that she did turn over this
large tranche of emails and made an
effort to do so mitigated the lack of
compliance previously it actually
implies the opposite of what you're
saying that you did do something wrong
and that this mitigates it lessens it
dampens the effect of that wrongdoing it
doesn't it doesn't even out if you steal
if you rob a bank and you return the
money it's a biggest mitigating aspect
but it doesn't mean you didn't rob the
bank
no I mean we didn't say that but what
what like and you know I can't say this
enough you know we had we have to do it
and we are doing a better job in
processing senior officials we have to
we're doing a better job at making sure
that from the top on down that people
understand the importance of records
record keeping and management and all we
can do is before looking and try to
improve and correct the system that we
have well no because then we said this
there was no there was no restriction
there was no regulation that says she
could not use personal email but you
admit she made mistakes the secretary
former Secretary Clinton would have
violated the law a matter for the FBI
investigation to decide whether they're
going to bring any charges well there
are there additional there are others
there are other thank you for there are
other reviews out there that we can't
speak to but one other question I want
to follow up on Brad's question you with
regard to hacking attempts you have
previously confirmed have you not that
there were efforts to hack into the
Secretary's email I think we have yeah
but I'm not sure but I mean hacking I
mean right but none of them that's why I
believe that none of them were
successful we have I think address that
before about so here's my next question
because you then
Brad asked you how do you know that they
weren't successful and you said I
misspoke I apologized nightstand do you
have any reason to think that there was
a no-no and Brett pointed out was the
the OIG report what I was saying I
misspoke was the thank you for giving me
the chance to clarify UID report doesn't
address them specifically the security
of her system including whether or not
any of the reported attempted hacks were
successful and for that I would just
have to refer you to her team to talk
about whether there were and we're
successful but to your knowledge our
knowledge they were them or not but I
don't know that's a comprehensive
knowledge but thank you guys I apologize
for this I I have to leave soon so
please any if we're exhausted just two
very quick questions one is about the
technicality that whenever a embargoed
report gets leaked or somebody breaks
the embargo usually the organization
lifts the embargo but it's not a similar
way similar way you the report is
everywhere and why are you still keeping
it why don't you really and I would
rephrase all this is the Inspector
General because now let me finish
teacher because they are not under the
State Department's authorization they
are separate entity and so they're the
ones who will release the report in the
second you mentioned about the Nara
Jason Baron the former director of Nara
spoke at a National Press Club last year
who said that before you know experts
and they clarified that all the
secretaries still today since the emails
came into being have been using not
using state gov the secretary Kerry is
the first one using either a mixture
yeah and and then but so this is not the
technicality the point is they said that
the Nara has put into place
when Secretary Clinton was some sort of
procedure that was not followed like by
2016 2019 you have a deadline to put
everything
on the web there won't be any you know
they won't have copies of the you know
all the archives will be on the web so
that something will and also what about
those 30,000 an email that she deleted
or did she keep them for even if you
have personally means you don't delete
them you you keep them for you
private yeah I can't speak to that you
have to direct that question to her
please I want to move on to couple by
there apologize to Joe nervous so what
is your reaction to the recent swap deal
between Kiev and Moscow well first of
all we we welcome today's news about
Nadia Savchenko and the fact that she
was returned to Ukraine and as you note
the government of Ukraine did make the
humanitarian decision to also release to
Russian servicemembers who were captured
on Ukrainian soil you know we're
delighted that she's home she was
captured as we all know in combat in
eastern Ukraine taken against her will
into Russia and you know we believe her
release and this exchange is an
important opportunity and it's an
opportunity for all sides especially
Russia to fulfill its commitments under
Minsk now under the Minsk agreements and
we think that it sets the right stage
now and should provide the impetus for a
complete implementation so moving
forward we want to see you know a
sustained credible ceasefire we want to
see full access for the OSCE we want to
see elections under Ukrainian law that
the OSCE standards we also want to see
the withdrawal of foreign forces and
equipment and finally the return to
Ukraine of full control of its
international borders these are the
steps that need to be taken concern
speech president poroshenko said he
intends to return Donetsk and Crimea the
same way he brought back said chenko I
mean are you concerned about that I'm
unclear what that you know the same way
that he would so what's the implication
there well in his statements when he
says he wants to bring back Crimea
and a NASA the same way they brought
Savchenko now sub chenko herself has
said she intends to return to combat
missions well first of all first of all
let's again let's take a step back here
sure I mean you know it was Russia who
occupied illegally and remains in Crimea
so we do believe that right Crimea
should be returned to its rightful owner
if you will which is Ukraine in terms of
eastern Ukraine you know we've been very
clear that Russia and the separatists
that it backs actively in eastern
Ukraine need to comply with them in the
commitments that they made under Minsk
which provides a path towards resolution
of this ongoing conflict as to you know
Nadia Savchenko
future plans hopefully she'll spend time
you know reconnecting with her family
and taking some well-earned rest what
she said was I am ready to once again
sacrifice my life on the battlefield for
Ukraine are you concerned about the
country being put into conflict once
again well look I mean she was a soldier
who was imprisoned while in combat in
eastern Ukraine fighting separatists
fighting Russian troops on the ground at
the time I don't know what her military
future holds but you know I think she's
speaking from that perspective really
quickly on the new Taliban leader yep
I'm gonna be to Lula what check with you
easy any kind of a that is designated
list under the US he's not no he's not
you said as if he was on the terrorist
test a terrorist he is not and how do
you react that he has rejected the peace
process
he has rejected the process Taliban has
looked at the peace process like I mean
just you know we would hope that he
would seize the opportunity he does have
an opportunity in front of him to choose
peace and to work towards a negotiated
solution we hope that he makes that
choice now he did have met thank you
real quick I gotta move quickly just me
for being a so apparently I'm just
asking for
as a matter of fact is he going to be a
next target if he jumped if he's gonna
forget who we target in the national
security interest of the United States
prisoner of conscience to release today
is a us by Jang journalist [ __ ] khaleja
Ismail of Nova do you have anything on
that we've seen those reports we will
have more to say later we do welcome her
release does the reaction to prime
minister Ave saying he will not visit
Pearl Harbor president avi saying he
will not visit Pearl Harbor in exchange
for no I mean we've said this before
look I mean our relationship with Japan
is strong strategic you know we have
built a partnership over with them over
the past 70 plus years that is durable
and forward-looking with an
acknowledgement of the sacrifices and
the pain that preceded the American
bombing seen Japan was extremely
regrettable um have you ever a few the
pressure from Japan to ask the United
States to apologize yesterday the United
States atomic bombing of the city were
extremely regrettable Hirshman yes um
well you know the president's going to
visit there
secretary Kerry visited her Oshima spoke
very movingly about his experience again
I would just say that you know we
acknowledge the pain of the past and we
look forward to building a stronger
future and you know with that in mind
that we need to move beyond the
conflicts and suffering and the
sacrifices and build a stronger alliance
and with respect to that please yeah
just a quick one yeah you can dispense
with it fast and it's I know it's like
the fifth day in a row but at least it's
now formally been announced that a big
door Lieberman is to be Israel's defense
minister to have any comment on the new
Israeli government and his appointment
to that job in particular thank you
we have seen reports and agreements been
reached to expand the coalition we've
also seen reports from Israel describing
it as the most right-wing coalition in
Israel's history and we also know that
many of its ministers have said they
oppose a two-state solution this raises
legitimate questions about the direction
it may be headed headed in rather and
what kind of policies it may adopt but
ultimately we're gonna judge this
government based on its actions we're
gonna work with this government as we
have with every Israeli government that
preceded it with the goal of
strengthening cooperation and we remain
steadfast in our commitment to the
security of Israel and then our
commitment to working towards a
two-state solution thanks guys